audio check testing testing one two
three one two three
her memes corrupt man
[Music]
everyone welcome back to another episode
of the trash taste podcast I'm Joey and
I'm with the boys as per usual Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Happy Hanukkah Mary Kwanzaa
whatever whatever holiday you celebrate
so I thought for Christmas I would gift
myself a new phone because this phone is
absolutely shattered how the [ __ ] did
you do that I was so I had it it fell
out my pocket while I was doing an IR
stream with you yes yeah and they've
smashed and now it is like pretty much
it's like usable 10 of the time it took
some what kind of works but it's just
frustrating all right so I thought well
I got a new phone what'd you get how
hard can that be well let's let's let's
hold up on that before we get it okay
just tell me what's good I don't know so
I you know originally I wanted like the
the Z fold whatever but I realized that
I can't mount it to my bike if I do
because there's no because it would be
like [ __ ] around yeah and they don't
mean bad flimsies well no because like
if you want a bike that goes on your
phone it's like because it's just one
like panel yeah you can just have these
like mounts that stick to it really
nicely yeah yeah
all there's no mounts right now and I
was like well should I I'm going to wait
for the mountain either right yeah no
and so I was like all right whatever
I'll go for the pixel so uh in Japan
right I was like you know what
I'm with um I'm with SoftBank I was like
okay well I'll just go to SoftBank
because I have a I've uh so this phone
was a Sim free phone right so I bought
it from Google yeah and then I went to
SoftBank and I got a Sim free or sorry a
SoftBank uh SIM card yeah yeah yeah so I
thought I could just go to SoftBank
and get a new Google pixel 7 but oh no
of course oh of course no no no no no no
no no no no no you would like to make a
purchase so here's what happened right
here's how it all went without doing
paperwork yeah so yeah first of all you
can't even just turn up the phone store
in Japan you have to book it's a new
system they introduced for kovid and
they haven't removed it yeah so you
can't just rock up at a store and buy a
phone now you have to book yeah yeah
which sucks because it's like what if my
phone breaks and I can't I don't want to
wait like two days yeah so anyway I make
this booking I say I want to buy the new
Google pixel uh Seven Pro whatever
even though I already don't really like
this pixel but I'm like oh well I won't
be burned a third time right so so I go
to SoftBank and yeah again I just want
to buy a new phone I already have a SIM
with this provider yeah I just want a
new phone
and so
I go in and also right now they told me
I couldn't have tethering on my phone
because I didn't buy the phone from
softbanks I thought oh cool well okay
I'll buy it from then this time and I'll
get tethering so I go in I'm like can I
have the pixel and they were like uh no
I was like what do you mean I was like
I'll I'll buy it all in cash I'm not
trying to get like a like a loan on it
I'm just trying to buy the phone you
know like
[Music]
in this name it's like hard and that's
how you know like it's gonna be tough
and I'm like why that's the polite
Japanese way of saying [ __ ] off yeah I'm
like why why can't I not buy this and
they're like okay so right now even
though your sim is with us and you'll be
buying the phone with us it still
wouldn't turn tethering on because the
Sim we just don't want to allow
tethering on I'm like okay okay I'm like
fine I didn't really want it that much I
mean it would have been nice but I guess
like I'll just I'll just get I'll just
get a you know maybe I can this I was
like why are you being like in there
about it it's not like I wanted to
tether anyway
but actually I was like actually wait
could I could I actually get a new SIM
card that is for this new phone
and could I then have tethering and they
were like No And I was like what they
were like oh because your Visa is
expiring in a month so we can't give you
a new sim plan wow and I was like oh but
I already have a plan with you they're
like yeah yeah and I was like and you're
not going to cancel that like no I'm
like so I can't so I can't get a new
plan
yeah that is the exact same plan so they
won't let me start a new plan that
allows me to tether with my same number
and everything it's no different they
won't let me do it because my Visa is
about to expire now I'm like hey I'm
renewing it yeah yeah on the back yeah
like no sorry like too many foreigners
have ran away so they changed the rules
and a lot of bad apple ruins the whole
world I'm like what the [ __ ] I'm like
all right fine I guess I don't I don't
need that at all all right fine can I
just get a new phone they're like no I'm
like
why can I not get a new phone and
they're like oh they're just trolling
you they're like oh because if you buy
this phone it won't work with this Sim
I'm like why not I'm like wait so you're
telling me the SoftBank phone won't work
with the SoftBank Sim I have and he's
like yeah yeah when it won't work I'm
like why and he's like oh because you
have a SIM free phone right now and this
this SoftBank Sim is a Sim free SoftBank
Sim and I'm like okay and he's like so
that that won't work on our phone
because our phone only accept except
SoftBank Sims and I'm like I have a
SoftBank Sim he's like no no you so you
have a free SoftBank Sim I'm like what
do you mean by that he's like oh this
only works on free phones unlocked
phones I'm like
so you're telling me the SoftBank Sim I
have won't work on your SoftBank phone
he's like no sir I'm like what are you
insane do you realize how stupid this is
they have to be trolling at that point
they're just like we really don't want
to give this guy I'm like I'm like what
do you he's like yeah so if you buy a
phone right now it will not work with
your current Sim unless you get a sim
that can only work on this phone so I'm
like how does that make any [ __ ]
sense are they trying to sell you a
phone or they wouldn't sell me the phone
at all no these because I had to have a
A or a plan only for their carrier but
like did they not give you like other
options being like but what you can do
is they were like get the [ __ ] out oh my
God they were like sorry nothing no can
do yeah
I mean you went through all that trouble
after a booking yeah and I'm like this
like I saw your Visa like illegal
immigrants obviously obviously you don't
deserve a phone I'm just like okay fine
[ __ ] me so my phone's broken I can't do
anything about it okay so now I I then I
afterwards I was like fine I'll go to
I'll go to like one of the other
characters areas and I'll see what I can
do yeah yeah and they were like oh yeah
because your Visa is expiring well it's
about to expire on paper it looks like
there's no no carrier will will let you
join so basically even though I already
have two more Sims with docomo for my
streaming bag they wouldn't give me one
but they did however docomo they did say
they were like hey once you if you buy
an unlocked phone from Google again and
you come back to us we can give you a
Sim the tethers hey talk about the goat
yeah I was like all right and they said
best of all because you have you already
have two sims with us if you have a
third with us we'll give you 10 discount
all the Sims and I was like oh music in
my ears so I'm gonna I'm gonna [ __ ]
cancel my softbanks in the moment I get
right I get I get my Visa honestly I
think I think like locked phones are a
[ __ ] scam why why yeah why why are
phones locked to a network this is right
and this is what I've always bought
unlocked phones yeah I'm like I don't
want to deal with this this locked
contract [ __ ] yeah but Japan has
designed a system that will punish you
for trying to do that like that
obviously you can do it and some
providers do it but all the big
corporations and the big networks really
don't want you to do it they do
everything in their power to not make
you do it which is fine
if it wasn't hard enough already to get
a sim plan like it's it's hard like in
the UK you can you can order a Sim which
I did like uh for some of my friends I I
ordered them Sims from the UK that they
shipped to Japan the company shipped it
to Japan ready so that when you come to
the UK it'll work it's unlocked work on
any phone I think I think the issue with
a lot of these like Japanese companies
is the fact that their main like Market
base is just Japanese people who are
probably never going to use another SIM
like they're just like in Japan the most
they'll travel is like [ __ ] I mean
why would they need why would you wait
so you're going to buy a phone but why
would you need another Sim you're not
going anywhere they've made a system so
stressful even compared to like the like
English contract and stuff like that
um that is so [ __ ] to deal with that
you'll just never question it and you'll
just keep yeah get upgrading your phone
you'll be like I don't want to deal with
it having to do this [ __ ] again yeah
this just sucks it's just a simple like
solution right yeah yeah you don't want
to deal with it where it's just like
it's kind of all about brand loyalty at
that point which I feel like is
ingrained in a lot of them is to go man
I travel your life
when I bought my other two sims they
were like no questions asked give this
man two SIM cards you know let's just do
it right now I do also find it
interesting how like going back to you
having a book an appointment at the
SoftBank because of like covert
restrictions
are we not beyond that point at this
point Japan isn't like Japan Japan is
still incredibly still so [ __ ]
paranoid about it because like I because
I went back to the gym recently after
and uh you know and like the local gym I
I went to like you can you know they're
obviously like oh you can like use the
app to see like how many people are at
the gym right now in case you don't want
to be like you know yeah full or
anything or you don't you know your
machines aren't available I'm like oh
that's great that's fantastic so before
I leave the house I go okay let's see
how many people are there and I usually
try to go like during the night because
that's when people yeah that's when it's
emptier so I went in and the gym I go to
split into two floors and it's like the
free weights are on one floor and then
the machines are on another floor and
it's and on the map it shows you like
okay there are this many people on this
floor there's many people on this floor
so one of the nights I was like oh okay
cool there's no one in the free weights
room so I'll just go there empty the
entire night right but I don't know if
this is the same with the gym you guys
go to but like now they've made it so
that if you're on like a cardio like
like a running machine or like a bike or
anything you don't have to wear a mask
oh not on my gym you still have to wear
them oh really okay so in my gym it's
like if you're on the running machine or
you're on like a bicycle or like any
cardio stuff so that you can [ __ ]
breathe properly yeah you can take the
mask off but if you're on a machine or
you're in free your weights you have to
have a mask it's so so dumb that Anytime
Fitness at least one near me you still
have to wear a mask on the cardio oh
really and like some people do it
yeah please just don't bother me because
I can't remember the message yeah it's
the same but like so I was like all
right I'll just go to the free weights
room whatever right it's empty as [ __ ]
right and you have to wear a mask even
in the free weights room right yeah but
I'm like it's like 10 p.m I know no
one's gonna come in no one's here yeah
so [ __ ] it I'll just take the mask off
so I can actually breathe right
just yesterday I get this text from the
gym no a text a text an automated
message text that basically reads uh
yeah so there have been reports that uh
you were at the gym uh on this day at
this time not wearing a mom no and I'm
like and are you serious yeah and it was
like and it was like uh you know we uh
you know we've revoked your credit card
access
you're now not allowed to spend it you
wanna Blacklist
and no basically he was like dystopian
it was so like it was so passive
aggressive too because it was like
you're not in trouble but it's just like
a warning you know it's like we we
require all uh you know gym goers to
wear a mask where it's necessary well
and I'm like
bro this room was empty who am I gonna
infect yeah I yeah I mean was there
someone who reports to you or did was
there someone who was like who was like
looking on the security probably someone
who just like the next day went on to
the security camera and was like oh this
[ __ ] Foreigner's not wearing a mask
I'm gonna send a passive aggressive
tweet to them okay maybe they have ai
that can tell when you're not wearing a
mask probably I need to turn on the
lights in the back okay oh [ __ ] oh yeah
we are dumb and forgot to turn on our
purple lights
I don't think any of us are anti-mask
but I think when it comes to exercise I
think you know there should be some
leeway there where it's like hey
especially when you're doing cardio yeah
I just yeah and it is annoying that at
least Anytime Fitness in Japan it
doesn't well at least there's like
[ __ ] millions of signs right yeah
same don't worry but most people I've
seen don't some people do it's weird
seeing who does and doesn't in Japan
right as a foreigner it's like all right
people expect me to not follow the rules
and it's like whatever but it's weird
it's odd seeing which Japanese people uh
follow the rules and I've noticed the
more ripped someone is in the gym in
Japan the less likely they are to wear
their mask I'm not kidding they're
absolutely who's going to tell them
who's gonna stop I'm not kidding you the
absolute Giga chat's in the gym don't
wear masks I'm not this is not this is
okay I I'm this is not me
being like do real men don't wear it's
like I've just noticed that the more rip
someone is in Japan the more the mess
might be like down here or down here
I know you know and people who tend to
be more timid I've noticed that yeah
it's weird that's weird I've noticed
that I'm not saying that like Google
shreds don't worry okay that's probably
why I got the text message because the
guy looked at the security camera I'm
like this [ __ ] skinny [ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] up his social credit
scores
it must be AI That's counting how many
people are in there next it's pretty
easy so it might be AI That's just if
it's an automated message yeah but like
I don't know it's just like I've never
gotten a message like that and I was
just like dumb fan I'm like first of all
there was no one there so how the [ __ ]
did they know and second like okay I get
it if there was like you know other
people in the room right that are in
close vicinity but for one this is an
empty ass room it was empty the entire
time I was there like before I came
after I left no one ever came in no one
even came close also what the [ __ ] is
the point of there being five air
purifiers in this tiny room yeah I mean
like I feel like Japan is like Japan's
like because I know this is with a few
places now where Japan's at this point
where it's kind of like in this limbo
phase where people don't know yeah yeah
people don't know whether to take you
know the same Corona precautions
whether to stick with them or not
because I've noticed some establishment
like you go to like restaurants and
stuff and all the signs are still up
over like the same like covid
precautions that would like there deep
during the pandemic were the
establishments follow them or not is
completely a coin flip yeah right now
you know which thing I I really want to
die and I hope this never I just want
this to stop right it's you only go to a
restaurant or a cafe yeah and they have
this in Japan I don't think they did
this anywhere else they had the screen
dividing you and your friend yeah yeah
yeah and so I hate that and so
I to me like again I'm I'm all for
taking precautions to separate you from
other customers because yeah you didn't
come in with them but if you come in
with say like uh someone you're dating
or your partner who you're married to
yeah and then they put this screen in
between you both in my head I'm like
what is this like I don't understand
it's like I'm visiting my partner in
jail
[Applause]
again I don't if that was like fine but
it's like if I want to share food it
becomes impossible oh yeah because you
have to go around yeah yeah and don't I
swear to God if you touch it in Japan
they freak out yeah because you know
maybe you have a big enough table where
you're like ah [ __ ] it you move it and
then like yeah
and they're like what are you doing put
it back and it's like oh what I mean he
just committed Warfare it's weird though
and I've been in other restaurants where
they'll be they'll just literally see
you coming together and they'll just
move it for you yeah it's so bizarre and
it it feels like incredibly inconsistent
which is what makes it annoying yeah
yeah and and you know like we did um I
uh I had my fourth shot recently I don't
even know if America's doing fourth
shots right or the only is the UK doing
fourth shot I have no idea it's covered
boosters well you know Japan became my
mail and it was like you should do it
and I was like fine I'll go do it yeah
yeah why not yeah you know who doesn't
want more protection sure just
collecting them all right yeah
and so I go and um get this thing I sit
down and uh this elderly guy starts
talking to me
um in Japanese but then he starts he
asks me if I speak English and I was
like oh yeah I speak English then he
starts speaking to me in like fluent
English and he's like he's like 70
nearly 80 I think yeah that's like the
shiny Pokemon of Japan yeah
smooth this most awesome pronunciation
of English ever and I was like oh wow
you start talking and you know you're
having a good time we're like laughing
joking and then they they're like some
person came over like stop talking not a
lot of talk it was maybe you could be
like for covert reasons you could be
spreading it I'm like are we still at
that stage where are we worried about
this like we're wearing masks like is
this apparently we're like whispering to
each other and then he get this old man
goes yeah
Japan is too strict sometimes
I'm an old Japanese he goes so
frustrated he was like shaking his head
when she told him off it was so funny I
was like oh man this guy is like he's
the energy of a young person yeah that's
probably why I can speak English right
yeah he's the voice of reason excuse me
obviously if an old Japanese guy speaks
English they've they've traveled around
you know
what's up it's it's um it's interesting
I mean it's weird seeing which aspects
of covert precautions they cling on to
yeah yeah and I don't necessarily feel
like it's of any
any real impact more of maybe like a
comfort thing yeah I don't really
understand a lot of the thought process
I mean it's gotten to the point right
now where I think at this stage in the
pandemic a lot of a lot of the
establishments that do these kind of
kind of things it's kind of more like
Theater which is quite sure which is
like which is why some people choose to
do it some people would choose not to
enforce it and it's kind of like
dependent on the establishment because
like yeah the I went to a restaurant the
other day where they still had the
screen like like uh disconnecting me and
whoever you're sitting down with yeah
and you know if you just ask them hey
can we remove this they were like they
would just go okay yeah yeah okay okay
sometimes they do sometimes they do
sometimes they do not want they are like
absolutely but that's the thing right
it's like it would be less frustrating
if they're at least consistent with it
if like if if it was like in the heart
of the pandemic where it's like there is
no [ __ ] there was no excuse It's
like this is this this is this and these
are the steps you want to take then it's
like okay well there's nothing I can do
about it I might as well live with it
yeah but like now as you said it's like
there are sometimes where I walk into
like a company right and like one
company you know I might be like oh [ __ ]
I forgot my mask they won't say anything
another one I walk in without my mask
and they just follow the freak the [ __ ]
out and I'm like can you at least be
consistent with this [ __ ] yeah yeah I
went into a combini to buy a mask so I
lost my mess and then they were freaking
out yeah yeah and I was like oh no no
I'm buying a mess yeah and they were
like how do we what is this protocol how
do we ah I can see the like gears
turning yeah like oh no because you know
often times yeah your mask yeah it's
like it's like you just put your mess in
your pocket on it maybe it fell out or
you know you dropped it somewhere you
put it in the car you know you've got to
buy a new mask yeah yeah it's like dude
I'm just buying a mask man chill out
yeah like I'm trying to follow and
adhere to the rules but sometimes it's
like it's it feels like you said it
feels more like theater and it's in it's
well I I think it's it's also compounded
by the fact that you know the country's
open now and there's no way to
distinguish us between like people who
have lived here during the pandemic and
tourists you know what I mean so it's
it's kind of I've because I've noticed
this a lot where before you know people
kind of treated you all the same
um because they knew you know you you
knew kind of like the rules here because
you must have been living here right
yeah but now they must come in with the
Assumption of you just came in this
country yesterday you don't know
anything you know what I mean and I I've
noticed that subtle like yeah Behavior
shift within like the past few weeks oh
my God I I recently had something like
that so I I recently did like a collab
for this like Japanese Channel
um whereas like they were interviewing
me in Japanese and I went to this like
Studio to go do it and it was run by
like Tokyo television or whatever sounds
like a proper production thing
everything it was really cool but like I
walk into the studio and and I can see
the set and it's like a like a long kind
of like semi-circle table with three
seats and I'm in the middle but there's
the huge [ __ ] plastic devices yeah
yeah right like that that's on on TV or
yeah and I'm like oh okay I mean well
it's Japanese TV so it's whatever the
problem was for one no one in this room
is wearing a mask and second of all I
walk in and I get introduced to the host
and the co-host and I just like straight
up shake hands with them none of us
wearing a mask and I'm like
so if I can come this close to someone
without a mask and touch them and then
immediately sit down and I'm protected
by these barriers I'm like I think we're
getting things the other way around like
I think the way that it in terms of
the way that the thought process is
behind that is that
because like you know there's still
acting shows going on right there's no
dramas yeah um and they're not wearing
masks show they don't have these plastic
dividers yeah they're acting as if like
it's in like a different world yeah I
think the reason why reality shows and
current TV shows in Japan that uh very
like all based on like real things or
reality
I think it's this kind of way of
messaging being like hey we are still
taking this seriously yeah
which but it's like in a pseudo way
because obviously like dramas and stuff
aren't held to that same standard just
because they're like I think it's
because you don't view it as something
that's real yeah yeah exactly but it's
weird because obviously it's real and
these actors are interacting yeah so
it's obviously like people don't
actually care about the precautions it's
like they just want to make them they
want to think that it it's being
considered because like being next to
someone with a plastic divider here in
the same room I don't it doesn't do
anything no it's just all for sure
what are you trying to show you're
trying to show that you're trying to
take kovid like seriously yeah taking
precautions it's like well yeah you know
really you're kind of half-assing yeah
if you were actually taking precautions
to stop it then you wouldn't do the show
to begin with yeah signal that you you
are still considering right which is
weird but at that point it's just like
you know like an empty attempt you know
it's just like Yeah Yeah we're
definitely making sure no one's getting
sick by putting these [ __ ] flimsy
pieces of plastic that are definitely
not stopping anything it's also like a
prime example of how
Japan is quite slow to adopt and then
get rid of things like they were quite
slow to adopt all these precautions yeah
yeah like it did actually take a while
while we were here compared to the
Western World and then now that they're
not no longer necessary or at least not
as necessary we're seeing that it also
is way harder to get rid of something
where people get accustomed to it in
Japan yeah like people out of just pure
comfort and having to deal with this
every day are being much more like
reluctant to get rid of it and these
systems because I don't know if people
necessarily even like them here I don't
I don't really understand because a lot
of people I've spoke to given they're
probably more foreign leaning like in
terms of mindset they they don't really
like it but also it's it's odd I think
it's not so much a matter of liking it
or disliking it I think it's just a
matter of I think I and I don't speak on
behalf of all Japanese people but I
think the general consensus is is kind
of just like well there's nothing we can
do about it like it or dislike it we
have to adhere adhere to it right so
it's like what can we do we I can say my
opinion about this it's not going to
change anything yeah I I honestly you
like don't know because even
pre-pandemic Japan was one of the few
countries that really embraced Mars
culture to begin with you know there
will be people wearing masks even before
the pandemic existed and it was a normal
thing to see in Japan was it as common
no but there was already this mindset
that was ingrained to be like to take
precautions you know wear a mask and now
like after the pandemic that's just
exasperated that idea to the point where
it's become more than just a precaution
but just become a habit I mean yeah
Japan is still you know even before the
pandemic they were still taking like
influenza shots every year yeah like no
one outside of Japan takes him oh no
they uh they do in uh America oh really
flu shots but is it like common place
where it's like it's I think yeah I
think they do it every year yeah really
it's I think it's other countries like
at least in the UK and Australia I don't
think we do no but in America they get
flu shots every year really because we
got we got like a message from our
company that was like Hey if you want
your flu shot this year you can come get
it oh and I was like what yeah I've
never had a flu no I've never taken it
yeah what do you mean like I've been
fine yeah but apparently in America it's
you get it every year oh wow okay I
didn't know I didn't know that either
until I was I think I've taken like flu
shots when I was a kid or something like
probably as a kid yes yeah I'm not sure
if it's common in the UK um I've never
heard of like normal healthy and healthy
adults yeah I thought it was normally
for elderly and then for younger people
yeah that's what I thought as well um
but yeah I don't know I mean the reason
why we obviously we spoke about this so
much because it is just genuinely
interesting and we're living it and
seeing it change all the lack of change
yeah the gym stuff is annoying yeah I
really wish yeah because they they
already I don't know about your
treadmills in your gym but they've like
constructed these like plastic like
boxes like they're like covers around
the entire treadmill oh like a yeah like
a it's like something you'd see out of
like a like a like an infection movie
like a pod it's literally like they've
built like a plastic pod from shower
poles and plastic what the [ __ ] no our
one is literally just the one it's
literally flimsy plastic it's my dream
is literally that and then they make you
wear a mask in it and to be fair like I
said most people I've seen half mess
skin
like they're not doing it uh and I've
never seen anyone get told off for it in
my previous gym this is given this was
like height of the pandemic because you
know sometimes bro you're [ __ ] dying
on that tread oh yeah and you're like
Brian to gasp for air yeah you pull the
thing down one time I was on it going
ham this must have been like 20 20. dude
like tapped me on the back and was like
dude mask put it up and I was like oh
okay sorry and I was like man that sucks
I'm like I can't keep running man
it's like when you breathe in deeply
like the [ __ ] cloth yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like I you know I think
there's people who are like dude you
can't breathe in this thing that's
[ __ ] you can but when you're running
all right I there is definitely an
argument there yeah when you're trying
to get that amount of airflow I mean I I
think one of the biggest reasons I
stopped going to the gym when was
because it just wasn't enjoyable
yeah so it's just like especially me
doing cardio with my asthma as well I'm
just like it's just it just stop being
like you stop feeling like I was making
progress and you just felt like I was
tortured torturing myself and I was like
a big reason why I just stopped going
and then I was like I'll go in The Mask
mandate is lifted for the gym and it
just if it will ever at this point never
did so I was like it's weird that it's
kind of kept on in the gym yeah because
I've genuinely thought the gym would be
one of the first places that they would
stop doing it because like in Japanese
schools and stuff right when they do
exercise they don't have to wear masks
yeah yeah so I kind of thought oh okay
well that's that's like a government
kind of and again that's why it's so
annoying it's like be consistent with
this [ __ ] yeah it's like if you're doing
physical exercise whether it's in a gym
whether it's in a schoolyard whether
it's [ __ ] out on the street you're
just running along the sidewalk it's
either mask on for everyone or mask on
for no one yeah that's right I think you
know it's been kind of frustrating
because at least in other countries us
and the UK it was kind of like on or off
it was like yeah we're telling you to
wear masks yeah or you don't wear masks
we're in Japan it's kind of like here
you do here you don't don't do it here
you have to wait for a moment here like
the whole dance of like in Japan let's
say you're walking outside yeah and you
know you don't have to wear a mask
outside and then you can go inside say a
restaurant if you put your mask on for
like 10 seconds and then you sit down as
you're walking down the moon you sit
down you're allowed to take your mask
off yeah and then it's like okay what is
this
because we all know once you sit down
covert's like oh wait yeah I'll wait
till you finish your meal
yeah I don't know I don't get it again I
I don't think any of us are trying to
come off as like complaining about like
like I think I'm I'm happy to comply and
wear a mask wherever is happy to help
and stop spread of it as long as rules
are consistent yeah you just have some
goddamn consistency and make some
[ __ ] sense yeah and let me run
without a mask yeah exactly that's why
I've been trying to like cycle more
because I'm just like dude I'm so done
being like doing exercise inside you've
leveled up you've gone from like indoor
exercise to like now outdoor exercise
right but the one thing that's better
about indoor exercising it's way more
convenient yeah it's easier to keep
track of let's say you know if you're
cycling you can't even like make a route
that comes back to your house yeah or
wherever you are right it's kind of like
the Gym's easy you rock up run the
treadmill lift the rock well that's why
I just do weights at the gym now like if
I'm doing just like cardio stuff I I
have a [ __ ] indoor bike that in my
house so I just I'm on that yeah because
we all did our health checkup recently
didn't we I haven't done it yet you
haven't done it I I missed myself
because I thought okay because like it
wasn't my fault like on on the [ __ ]
company slack it was like okay you're
Joey your [ __ ] one is on the the 21st
of November and I'm like all right got
it nailed it putting it in my calendar
put on both my calendars and I'm like
all right I got this day locked all good
yeah and then I'm like the night before
I was like okay I should probably open
up the the papers just to you know
double check I need a you know what I
need to bring for tomorrow and I open it
up and it's like okay so this is all
your paperwork for your uh Health
schedule for the 20th of November I'm
like oh
that's today
uh that was three hours ago oh no so I I
quickly rang them up and I was like ah
the [ __ ] is this I was supposed to go
today and they were like oh yeah I guess
there was some kind of mixer blah blah
blah so now I'm doing it like three days
before Christmas oh so I'm like that's
good at least it's before Christmas
merry Christmas you have a Christmas
presents yeah your cholesterol is B
Merry Christmas
I'll pray for B and cholesterol dude
I've been on the C train for like years
for cholesterol yeah my cholesterol's
bad oh damn I'm praying I get a better
urine score this time I don't know how I
[ __ ] up my urine it's annoying because
if you see like a C or D in urine like
you see a C or D and cholesterol you're
like I know what I do yeah I know how to
fix this it's just a urine thing testing
what is that testing skill issues
yeah your blood is just built it like I
don't know what that like what are they
testing for In The Blood as well it's
like acidity I think in terms of the
urine what maybe it's like acidity in
the urine right where it's like and then
something to do that at least there's
something to do with your kidneys and
your bladder and your whatever but yeah
it's like at that point it's like do you
drink more water than anyone how do you
have sugar maybe I drink too much
my kidneys were like yo can we stop
hydrating actually like I know right
it's come on it's genetics too your
parents or your grandparents could have
[ __ ] you up yeah I'm pretty sure
that's why my cholesterol so hard
to buy PC specialists
hello from the team at PC specialist
ring in the new year with a custom PC
specialist gaming PC not confident in
building a PC yourself Joey build your
next Generation gaming PC with PC
Specialists is Hughes custom
configurator or choose from their
recommended specifications whether
you're a gamer Enthusiast content
creator or a professional because you
can't be all four of them at the same
time PC specialist has you covered with
a wide range of components to choose
from to suit your budget and needs I'm
actually wires inside of your PC will be
a thing of the past as PC Specialists
neatly cable manage every single PC and
each PC goes through an extensive stress
test to ensure reliable stability and
Optimal Performance all PCS are powered
by Windows 11 playtime anytime baby so
get yours now by visiting the link in
the description below and using Code
trash for a discount at the checkout
back to the episode three over Christmas
have you guys start your Christmas
shopping yet no don't remind me bro God
I just do you know what's like at this
stage do you know the question that's
scares me the most now it's not it's not
me asking people what they want to
Christmas or going Christmas shopping
but when you get to December and you get
about 10 questions from either your
friends or family asking you what do you
want for Christmas for Christmas I'm
like I have no [ __ ] clue
well that's why like my parents took the
easy route since like I was in high
school and they're just like here's some
cash just buy what you want and like you
know some people will be like oh that's
so like you know heartless like you know
your parents should be thinking about
what to get you you know like a gift and
you know making mean something and I'm
like no if anything like I don't know
what I want so like it's better if I
just get the cash and I just buy what I
want you know so it's whatever but like
I but if I do that for other people then
it pisses them off so I'm just like well
[ __ ] what am I supposed to do because
I'm so bad at buying gifts
awful buying gifts but I realize I'm
also awful at buying gifts for myself
for myself yeah and I'm I'm like the
number one culprit of like when someone
asks me what do I want I'm like I don't
[ __ ] know the problem with me as well
is that like because I either just want
like you know the things that I want the
short list of things that I want in my
head for like the immediate future or
like the far future is always like the
two extremes right so it's like when
hockey's like oh what do you want for
for like as a gift you know what do you
want me to give you and I'm like ah I'm
debating between a house and a chocolate
bar
it's just like there's nothing in
between that I want it's like if I have
a house that'd be great yeah well get me
a moss block I kind of I'm craving a
moss bar right now it's like well you
know I know exactly what you mean like
everything you want is not like
Christmas gift it's not it's not in the
budget yes it's not it's either too
cheap or way too like or like a life
[ __ ] goal
what is that like the perfect price of a
Christmas gift in your mind it depends
on who you're giving it to yeah right
yeah because like I kind of tear it out
in my hair yeah
no I tear it out I'm like if it's family
members then okay you know the budget
can be I don't know anywhere between 50
to 200 right like depending on what it
is if it's like a mate right that you
you know you might see every now and
then like then you know you can usually
get some pretty good gifts between like
20 25 dollars right yeah so that's
that's what I kind of aim it to do but
then there's that mental game right of
like all right I'm getting my friend
something that's like around 25 what if
they give me something that's way more
expensive it's the game of like
Christmas chicken right it's it's like
you don't want to be that guy who just
gets like a really cheap gift and the
mate gets like a really expensive
exactly but also you don't want to be
that mate who's a bit overbearing and I
was just like well got a gift that's way
too overly expensive you're right you
know what I mean yeah it's tough I think
that I
in my mind is like let's say I got you
an 80 gift I got you a 200 gift yeah I
don't view it as okay I value God more
yeah so yeah maybe I found a gift that
was perfect for Joey that was 80 bucks
right that sucks that I found the
perfect gift for Grant there was more
than I wanted to spend yeah but I don't
think God would ever buy it for himself
and I think this is a great gift so then
it's like okay in my head these two are
like both the perfect gift but obviously
the price is different yeah yeah so that
that's how I kind of look at it yeah but
it's tough it is tough because then you
don't want they might not view it that
way yeah and especially like if you're
on the receiving end of that as well
it's like oh you know oh my friend could
be like oh I got you this perfect gift
it's like a 200 wine decanter or
something yeah oh I got you a tender
stubby holder Merry Christmas it's like
it's like it's like you know they like
that [ __ ] but it's like well I I think
it's all good when it seems like you
didn't put nearly as much effort as they
do oh yeah not necessarily monetarily
but like they're like oh yeah I put way
less thought into mine yeah and you put
way too much thought into yours the
thing it's like oh the thing is there's
been points where I I have received like
expensive gifts right but it's like
price isn't always the thing that's the
most valuable when it comes to like gift
giving if there's a gift that's perfect
for someone like it could be cheaper it
could be more expensive I've like showed
out for like a gift that's more
expensive when I think a mate would like
or make a family yeah
we'd really really enjoy this and
everything like that yeah um but also
I've received like cheap gifts that were
just like perfect for me
um that's that I could tell they put
like a lot of thought into yeah
um and I feel like there's that's the
real kind of
that's that's the real trickiness of
like gift giving okay here's a question
I want to ask then do you guys like
getting surprise gifts yeah
I am no surprise as in like as in like
gifts where it's like you want exp it's
not like a even even if it's like
because like for me ever since I was a
kid whether it's like birthday or
Christmas or anything like that any kind
of Celebration I want to know what I'm
getting
no I hate it I hate it yeah right
sorry you hate not knowing what you're
gonna get yeah not knowing what I'm
gonna I hate receiving surprise gifts
why
it makes me feel okay if there's one
thing that I hate even though even
though I know it's even though I know
most people don't think like this right
yeah this is just a me problem I just
hate feeling like I'm indebted okay
like even if they expected nothing from
Return they were just giving it to me
out of the kindness of my heart and I
know it and I know that and I know the
surprise gift but what occasion okay
even even if it's like no occasion right
like it's like you know uh [ __ ]
friend just came back from somewhere
you're not expecting any kind of gift
but they're like hey I got you something
and I'm like it's cool receiving it
because I'm like oh [ __ ] they care for
me yeah but now I feel bad because now
I'm indebted and I feel like I need to
return the favor it is so nice if they
would be like yeah someone is giving
their surprise gift they're not the type
of person who would then expect
something bad no no
would you want the solution then to be
them not give you a gift what is the
solution to this problem the solution
would be for me to like reprogram my
brain to not okay such a [ __ ] idiot
so what do you prefer having this
anxiety of debt or not receiving the
gift but like uh which one's more
powerful
see that's the tough part right and
that's why I think my solution
personally is for me to be the [ __ ]
to give special gifts no no that's
that's my my solution yeah my solution
if I give people gifts before me I will
never feel indebted that is my solution
and it's it's I mean I've had this Howie
this much of the same answer I've had
this before because I know Malin feels
the same way and every time I give
Maiden a gift she has the exact same
look in her eyes as I do when I receive
the gift yeah I know I'm like it's like
an Asian thing
even if it was something that say like
they hand made it because I've received
like handmade gifts from like my friends
before right of like some cool [ __ ] and
I'm like and and you know there's no
monetary value to that because it's not
something they bought right it's
something they've made right so I think
it's more so just the fact that they
went through the effort to think about
me and to get something that they think
I would like yeah that makes me feel bad
no it's it's not it's not even it's not
even does that make sense to me it's not
even like anything to do with like
monetary value or anything like that it
could be like a one dollar thing I'd
still feel bad
okay okay
if you uh
if for me like
if you need to borrow like five pounds
five dollars off of me yeah does do you
do you remember that [ __ ] and you were
like I am going to pay this back one day
or can it sometimes like oh absolutely I
I make a like a subconscious thing of
like okay uh you know next time you're
paying I'll be like oh yeah by the way
yeah you owe me five bucks but I'll be
like just whatever figure it out I keep
a very rough balance in my head of who
who's oh is what no if I if I borrow
money off anyone I like write that [ __ ]
down on my phone I'm like I owe this
person this much money yeah it's it's
just like I'm a [ __ ] Lannister the
debt is being paid no no shame whether
they like it or not I find that people
are way more forgetful when it's like oh
hey I'll get you a coffee and then you
don't think like oh he spent five bucks
like he got me a coffee and then it's
very easy to forget that someone got you
a coffee even though that's the exact
same monetary value Plus work of
bringing it to you yeah yeah so like
that that's harder to keep track of
right yeah then that's normally how what
you you have like the the
um the very casual balance sheet between
you and your friend that's in your head
it's like okay he bought me five coffees
I am three drinks or something you know
right yeah so you kind of like pay it
back right that's how I'm more so like
because when do I actually need to
borrow cash I don't it's like can you
get this drink yeah yeah yeah that's
more so what my life comes down when
have you when's the last time you ever
asked for cash
I mean like a very long time I did like
a week ago yeah but I paid it back like
immediately yeah yeah but that that's me
as well when that's like 500 bucks
that's different
it's not it's not it's not quite though
okay
can you you've got a spare tennis I have
the same energy of like can I have the
500 bucks and I'll give it you back oh
my God it sounds like a car was because
I forgot to get ATM out of the crane
game all right okay 500 bucks for crane
games right now yeah I'll pay you back
later I don't know where this came from
it doesn't matter if it's like a
surprise gift or even if it's just like
a casual favor or something if I if I
feel like oh someone a favor they're
like that that that keeps me up at night
because I'm just like when I'm when is
this when am I gonna feel like okay I'm
100 comes down to uh viewer money though
I'm pretty sure and how you how you
valued because you know time equals
money yes we I think you don't want
someone's time energy or like kind of
money and how you viewed it and how
you've been brought up viewing it I
think it definitely ties into that like
if you look back at how you were taught
about money it's probably the same kind
of mindset as like um now with the gift
giving of like right if somebody gives
you something you give it back yes you
know if somebody I mean that is like
super ingrained into Japanese yeah okay
I don't think it's money I just what was
that was that of a distilled into you
where money if someone lends you money
or you work you have to work for your
money you have to do like I think all
comes down to that where you put a
certain value on time and money in your
head because you're because you're
raised to and you value that and so I
think that that carries on in in odd
ways and odd course I think that's right
no I I I I I don't think so because to
me I'm I'm like trying to like
psychoanalyze myself right now I never
want to feel like
I'm not valuing our friendship or our
relationship as much as they value I I
never want them to feel like I don't
value our friendship or our relationship
as much as I do so whenever someone goes
out of their way to do something nice
for me I'm like that that's I you know
I'm [ __ ] touch because I'm like [ __ ]
but yeah but then I guess that that
means you're then you're saying that the
value of the friendship or what value
you bring to it is is you can Define it
with objects or monetary like value just
saying if you give me a gift and I don't
give you one back I didn't value the
friendship as much as you whereas I
disagree because a lot of people can get
way more fulfilling things out of a
friendship like you might have like
let's say you know you've helped me out
way more than you realize and then I
give you a gift in my head that's not me
saying hey now you owe me one it's like
no no I know that a lot yeah but that's
what I'm saying like that means you're
viewing it the way you're subconsciously
looking at it is like okay there is this
has value and this is how the Friendship
works I think I think I think is tied to
the whole there might be a little bit of
that but I think in my head there's more
so the matter of like I would rather you
spend that money and time on yourself or
other people other than me yeah because
you guys said you feel bad
I feel bad because I in my head I'm like
that could be a gift or a money span or
time spent finding that gift or whatever
or time spent making the money to buy
that gift that you could use on yourself
or other people in your life sure
appreciation yeah yeah and that's why
and that's why like that's that's what I
mean by I feel bad because it's like I
already for the most time I already
value the relationship that I have with
this person just them being a maiden
then you know [ __ ] with me right and
it's like
you know like you know them like you
know [ __ ] vibing with me right it's
like just the fact that you're my friend
is like more than enough for me right so
it's like I would rather as a friend I
would rather you I mean I appreciate
getting the gift no matter how much it
costs right no matter how quick or long
it took to get that gift but in my head
I'm like I already appreciate you enough
as a friend and as a friend I would
rather see you use that time and money
on other people than me yeah because I
don't need it so you know for the most
part yeah yeah I agree with that
um I think
so going back to like I think a lot of
everyone has a different thing that they
really put a lot of weight on you know I
think that like as I've got older uh and
had to balance more friendships and seen
how they work in more adult situations
I'm like okay some people when they like
really appreciate a friendship they'll
go out there they make gifts some people
will go out of their way to arrange a
really cool hangout and they'll do
everything right yeah some people really
value maybe how quickly you text back or
how quickly you stay in touch right yeah
it's like everyone has like value that
they assign to certain things yeah and
it's just about being an adult is trying
to figure out hey this friend he really
likes it when I reply to text quickly or
this friend really appreciates it when I
give them a gift that you know they
didn't think about or this friend really
appreciates it when I take them out for
a good time and so I think it's it's
just like you're probably in a different
category where you value something else
more in a friendship than a gift yes and
to you a gift seems like oh [ __ ] I gotta
I have to give this back to show that I
appreciate you where it's like no I can
I would normally show it in my own way
which might be I'll hang out with you
and chat with you for hours and yeah
you're the first person I want to go to
for this type of topology you know what
I mean yeah it's weird it's it's cheesy
but it's like to me it's like your
presence is a gift me too me right it's
like it's like just the fact that you're
there and you're my friend I agree more
than anything it's it's cheesy but I
feel the exact same way when I'm just
like [ __ ] I've just just just being
around me is enough of them that you're
my friend is like all that I could ask
for I'm sure you've probably met that
type of person who's always buying gifts
even though like they're broke yeah
and like that's just like I think that's
just like a personality trait where yeah
they really value being able to
physically show that they they enjoy the
friendship or whatever it is yeah that's
how in their head it's like fulfilling
to kind of give back like physically
with like an item by the way is there
any friends of ours watching this
uh
I say if
you give I'm not gonna be like get the
[ __ ] out of here right like I'll take it
but like
I'll take it okay just know that you
don't have to here's the thing no no no
we're all pretty we all do pretty pretty
good money-wise yes it becomes way
[ __ ] harder to buy gifts to people
who can buy things yes this has been a
me issue no matter what
I said let's say I have all the money in
the world how do I buy you a gift card
when I know if you want something you're
just gonna buy it
cause you can afford it but that's why
that's why I I'm not going up to to
[ __ ] stupid money yeah I'm not going
to do that but that's why again I value
just like you being there and when I
need you or you know when you want to
hang out and stuff like that I I value
that kind of relationship in a
friendship so much more than I ever have
in my life yeah like okay I think I
think this goes back to like another
thing as well I don't know if this is
like Anyway related right but I think
one thing I've always just not hated but
just felt a little bit uncomfortable
with was kind of like being the center
of attention and I I I don't know it's a
podcast I don't know how ironic this is
I don't know how ironic this is you're
about 130 episodes
I still had a bunch of shows but I
[ __ ] hate being the center of
attention I don't know because like
there's a very clear distinction between
a center of attention when performing
yeah and the center of attention in your
personal life yes and to me right I love
being the center of attention when I'm
when I'm I'm performing or doing stuff
I'm sure we all do yeah well it's ego
stroke very nice yeah personal life it's
like all right sometimes yeah sometimes
no yeah I sometimes like it sometimes
I'm like no yeah yeah but like for
example for example what I mean for
example like birthday parties right like
do do you like having a birthday party
for your birthday specifically set up
all right all right for you I got an
opinion right right you know what I mean
you know what I mean no I think the
birthday party the entire Vibe is up to
whoever's organizing it or you yeah like
you can make a birthday party feel like
a normal party just with the excuse that
it's my birthday yeah you know and
that's how I like it where it's like hey
let's all get together it's just an
excuse to get everyone in the same room
yeah I'm not about to be like hey guys
let's toast to me tell me what you love
about me show me your presence there are
people like that but I don't know and
that's where I'm like bro come on
yeah I I love that Vibe like that
birthday party Vibe where it's just like
any excuse for everyone
together everyone you come out in the
same room and just hang out but I've
also had birthday parties and been to
birthday parties where it's just like
guys it's this guy's birthday guys
so this guy's and I just I I hate that
feeling having a day that is just
centered around you basically I just I
just I it was I think it's selfish it
was something that just never I never
felt comfortable with you know what I
mean you see it's selfish and I think
like a lot of people argue being like
well it's the one day of the year you
can be selfish no right so you know
everyone's having a birthday 24 7. you
know what I mean you're not special
like yeah you can have a day why are you
gonna make the day about you all right
like you can it can be your day without
me without putting down everyone else
yeah yeah before someone turns out to
your party they're probably doing chores
doing laundry they don't give fact that
it's your birthday you know what I mean
like everyone's just you know hey I'll
especially as an adult I just think that
like you it can be your day without
making it like everyone you forcing on
everyone else that it's your day yes
yeah yeah I agree I think you can have a
nice day have the perfect day you want
yeah but you know just just let that see
like that's what I that's what I really
appreciated about my birthday this year
right because like it was while we're on
tour and we were doing a show in Ohio
of all days and uh
and like and to me that was like the
perfect scenario for like a birthday
party right because it was like it
wasn't like the entire show was about oh
it's Joey's birthday today [ __ ] it
was like just a thing that was just
tacked on at the end I didn't even
[ __ ] know about it I got a python in
my face yeah
in my opinion that was like the best
birthday party yeah because it's like I
wasn't the center of attention I was
just like a little tack on thing where
it's like by the way yeah it's Joey's
butt yeah you know because the re the
reason I bring that up is you know
having a day centered around you gives
me the same kind of feeling of just like
getting a surprise gift or something
where it's just like I I'm getting now
all the eyes are on you yeah yeah I'm
I'm getting attention from like people
around me and everything like that and
I'm just like I I was just comfortable
just chilling and just just hanging out
and not saying it's exactly the same
thing like I'm trying to like trying to
like understand why but I'm just saying
kind of gives me like the same feeling
of just like oh I didn't expect this um
not that I'm ungrateful about it it's
just I don't know how to handle it or
deal with it and that's completely just
a me thing it's it's a complete judgment
like that as well yes I was gonna say I
was like because it feels like weirdly
like it's very easy to be like hey I'm
on camera all day I got so much
attention I'm like this time
[Laughter]
I'm gonna have some attention today
meanwhile I post 15 Vlogs and then
[ __ ] stream for six seconds you know
what I mean like I feel like it's a bit
ironic for me to be like no I'm good I
was like you know I think I get enough
in my mind is probably it is pretty stem
from I get enough attention I'm chill
with that yeah yeah but I wonder if I
didn't do this would I want more
attention I think yeah no I've been kind
of the same as like not not ever since I
was a kid or anything because I feel
like it's not up until a certain age
where you become self-aware about that
kind of [ __ ] where you start you realize
being like Oh okay maybe I don't want
all the attention for my like you know
because like when you're [ __ ] the
inverse yeah well like when you're
[ __ ] five years old right like you're
not gonna be like guys play pins on me
I'm not I'm not the host or anything
just go have fun like you know of course
you know like you don't have that kind
of self-awareness but like it's not
until I feel like you're around I want
to say like 13 14 like when you enter
like high school or middle school where
you start to realize you either turn
into the kid that wants to be the center
of attention or you turn into the kid
that doesn't yeah man I had this
fantastic English teacher okay I was
just right she was like the best English
teacher man was she angry though like
but like you know when some I don't know
if you ever had these teachers then they
they were super angry but not because
they were just life wasn't going their
way they were [ __ ] angry because you
weren't listening and they were very
passionate about it right right she
cared so much about English and teaching
it yeah and it was like she was
terrifying she was by far the scariest
teacher like all the like everyone was
scared of her and she used to go off and
I for some reason you always stuck with
me it was like if a kid was like making
noise and [ __ ] she would just tear into
them in front of the whole class and be
like oh
oh Charlie is it because you don't have
enough attention at home that you want
to try and get some attention in the
classroom
she would just destroy them go into them
that's all with these kids I'm like 12.
oh [ __ ] hell that's something when a
kid traumatized kid would just like do
some [ __ ] she'd be she would always just
rinse how they wanted attention they
weren't getting it at home so it's like
oh so you're not getting enough at home
so you decide to ruin my classroom
trying to get attention then your
pathetic life or something like that you
go off dude excuse me holy [ __ ] she's
awesome she was so good at teaching
English yeah it's very fun okay no I get
it now I okay yeah I'm I'm proud of the
code so the point was that yeah they're
stuck with me and the kids want
attention and that you realize you don't
want attention to what you do and what
you're doing yeah okay that's why I
brought that out right what what up what
gives me happiness
God is justlyn right now he's like I
figured out yeah I've I've just I've
just been it's like Will Smith I'm just
like why I've just been trying to like
[ __ ] psychoanalyze my mind to be like
why am I so why am I such a [ __ ]
idiot why am I so [ __ ] difficult with
the simplest of things right yeah
um yeah for me like what actually gives
me happiness is making the people around
me happy seeing the people around me
happy so when protagonists so so when so
when the goal is to make me happy and to
like when people are like actively
trying to make me happy by just doing a
nice thing or something that just feels
weird to me because my happiness comes
from just seeing people around me happy
right yeah that is the most harm
protagonists
happiness comes from giving you a gift
that's the Paradox I'm stuck in right
now Connor I don't know how to escape
by being upset about receiving the gift
you're making them upsets
I feel bad you feel better no I feel
pressured you feel pressured yeah maybe
you gotta make them upset yeah maybe
actually it's it's and again that's why
it's a mean problem it's it's literally
I'm like like I said I'm not upset it's
kind of like you just break me where you
just putting me into like a logic Loop
right I'm just like I don't know what to
feel I know I should feel free and then
like and then like I get blue screens
that's me with social interaction like
yeah I don't know it's it's I always try
and like psychoanalyze and try and
figure out why the [ __ ] I like think
certain ways or do certain things I'm
like yeah what what made me think this
way because yeah you hear what other
people think and I'm like oh why do I
not why do I not yeah why do I not think
that way yeah why do I not why like why
is it where that I differed in terms of
that yeah trying to figure it out and
yeah it's normally always something I'm
trying to I'm trying to think if there's
like a weird birthday party in my
childhood that just traumatized me and
to have like my own birthday but did you
guys ever have like your own like
special birthday parties as a kid I
don't know if that's like a thing right
yeah I'm just trying to think it might
maybe the way I thought about it is that
like I used to have a childhood friend
who had a birthday two days before mine
right and so a lot of birthday parties
were joint books I remember this yeah
yeah so that might maybe be like a
subconscious reason I don't want to be
the center of attention this was in the
age where like you don't get to choose
who's coming to the birthday party yeah
everyone invites everywhere yeah I have
like really weird memories like very
vague though
I [ __ ] know why it's because my
birthday is like end of May which is
deep during exam season no matter what
before that before what about before
that yeah before example like when
you're in like elementary school because
my birthday was in summer so I never got
to spend it anyone I was like yeah
so I just got I just got used to never
having a birthday party for a lot of my
like I say teenage years especially
right yeah I didn't have any you didn't
I think I had like really tiny ones with
like the close friends because when it's
in school you can do like much bigger
ones yeah because like you I yeah I
would go to like people's birthday party
like everyone would be there and then
you just got used to like oh okay you
wanted to have like a birthday party or
something well sorry revising for exams
or sorry way on holiday or something
like that I'm just trying to think I
literally can't remember a single
birthday party between the age of 10 and
18. I'm trying to remember because I
remember those birthday parties I
remember are the most extravagant and
I've seen yeah I think sausage rolls
that they felt like the most extravagant
because I've always like sausage rolls
and crisps and then like some like a
sandwich to just like dig in did you
ever like did you ever like ever have
like a birthday party where you went to
like a [ __ ] McDonald's or like some
place yes
the McDonald's flavor yo that was the
[ __ ] man
hell yeah there was no playpen really we
had to play pen like 10 minutes drive
from my house and that was like where
I'd say up until maybe the age of
six or seven was like just just
McDonald's playpen party and then a
genius branding of them I think after
that I [ __ ] love McDonald's from age
[ __ ] City yeah and then literally
yeah the other birthday party that I
remember really vividly was uh I went to
I I think it was like seven or eight it
was like right after the playpen era um
the playpen Arc of my birthdays it was
uh my dad organized a day where we went
to go see the premiere of Finding Nemo
let's hope yeah and so my dad would make
these like invitation cards right and he
would send them off to like the parents
like and being like you have been
invited this is the exclusive
Joey's eighth birthday premiere of the
red carpet of finding [ __ ] Nemo and
and then literally just after that it's
just a blank period of I don't remember
what my birthday buddy and then when I
was my 18th birthday party I just got
stupidly wasted I mean actually you know
what I think about it I can barely
remember anything from my childhood
that's a problem that's a different
problem that's straight up I'm thinking
about it now I can I can scarcely
remember I I have bits and pieces well
you remember you're a member of like all
the I think everything you've talked
about you're concerning your childhood
has all been on trash days right like
just like a lot of core memories like
beating the French kid yeah that's a
very cool memory yeah I have a bunch of
other scattered memories but I couldn't
tell you what that's well that's that's
why trash days is such a weird entity
because most of the time I don't
remember this [ __ ] and then we're having
like this random ass conversation and
they're just like [ __ ] like I just
get a flashback yeah some birthday
parties I just started getting like
flashbacks too and I was like oh yeah I
remember one of the hypest things
because like
um you know I mean I might think about
my parents weren't like broke or
anything but my mama just didn't believe
in spending money on certain things yeah
okay
um I'll put it that way I'm almost gonna
kill me
um so like if we ever went to the cinema
it was like no you're not allowed to get
any of the snacks or anything like that
oh [ __ ] no not at all right just get to
come in and we'll bring maybe a snack or
two from Tesco's or something yeah which
is fair enough I think that's yeah you
know if I want to get that yeah but I
remember when Goblet of Fire came out I
got to go and so on my friends birthday
parties to go and watch it yeah and they
were like hey any of the sweets whatever
you want and I was like what
for real and that was like the hype
issue that was generally the highlight
of like my young like life I just
remember that [ __ ] so much oh man how
awesome that was that was so good the
other like Ben and Jerry's pick and mix
oh I wish I never go outside not even
birthday parties but it wasn't me I had
to go to one of the rich kids to get it
yeah I didn't even think like I had a
rich kid friend who did that or anything
like I just remember when I was like I
was a last minute because someone else
checked out oh okay
I feel that you kidding me kidding me
because the other thing I remember about
like Cinemas is like we used to the the
supermarket below the cinema we used to
just buy a shitload of like candies and
chips and stuff like that just shove
them in someone's bag and you weren't
allowed to do it yeah yeah and like I
remember one of like the [ __ ]
managers I guess or whatever was just
like you know someone in like the 40s or
50s whatever was just like what year
it's like pointed to my friend with the
bag and he's like what's in there my
friend's like
jacket like why are you going to jackets
like it's cold in the cinema it's like
all right well he I think he knew but he
was like you're 14 years
why would you I I bro I don't wanna I
was like I'm sorry bro I'm not paying 12
for a [ __ ] box pump like if somebody
is going to links to bring snacks in
they they were never gonna buy the
popcorn yeah exactly so you've taken
away their snacks or not laying them in
it's not gonna make them buy popcorn
yeah maybe like one out of ten but like
is that really the you really want to
piss everyone off yeah I don't know it's
also like to do with birthdays I don't
think like I never had like that rich
friends but did you have that rich
person in your classroom who wasn't
exactly a friend but for their birthday
party they just invited everyone in
their class yeah yeah yeah oh I didn't
have that did you never have no most of
people invited everyone I wish because
you know they were these type of kids
that would have bouncy castles
this is this is on another [ __ ] level
man yo you go there like they bought
their friendship man you know bro I'm
jealous I would have milked the [ __ ] out
of him if that was the case I didn't
have that at all because like I think
like bouncy castles and stuff like that
like it was never like a birthday thing
it was always like uh like like a local
like Carnival type of thing where it's
just like like twice a year in this
random open field they'd just be like
yeah let's just see what happens if we
put 20 bouncy castles here you know I
have so many memories scattered of like
being forced to go to like dinners with
people my parents I don't I have no idea
who they are yeah I'm just having to be
in a restaurant for ages because your
parents are drinking yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're like they're talking having a
good time and they're just like [ __ ] I'm
so bored oh I had to do that in Japan
once lately I went like I think I was
like 14 or something and my my dad has
this like age-old friend a Japanese guy
can't speak a word of English right
um for some reason my dad calls him
Brian even though his real name is
Satoshi I don't know where he got that
from but basically I remember but I was
in like an Izakaya and I was like 14
right you can't drink in a [ __ ]
Izakaya 14. yeah so I'm just sitting
there just like kind of just chilling
whatever just you know sipping water and
my dad in his in his drunken stupa he's
like son come over here and I'm like yes
Father what is it and he's like
translate what I'm about to say
and I'm like okay my dad says something
to Brian I say it in Japanese and then
Brian goes all right can you translate
this back to him I did that [ __ ] for
seven hours
just sitting here like it was a [ __ ]
job to do and I'm like Father you know I
can make a living
and you're making me do this [ __ ] for
free dog I am expecting the biggest gift
for Christmas this year yo he was
training you man he was training me dude
he was like this will be good for you
son yeah for me there would like my
parents they would always have like I
don't know like my family is big but
what's even bigger is my family's
Network so I would always have like yeah
my mum would always have a friends that
she could visit or well my dad would
have like a friend in Thailand or in
England that they were visiting
obviously when I was a kid I would have
to go with them all right I would go to
the I would go to my parents friend's
house and I just remember like the my
biggest thing was just
it was the one place I didn't want to be
because I was like why you take me away
from my [ __ ] games to make me sit
down and drink tea and go to this house
or whatever and just sit here and do the
people I don't know don't talk to people
I don't know you know yeah that's
horrible but did I remember do you
remember like how easy it was to
entertain yourself when you were a kid
oh yeah I don't know a lot of memories
of being bored I'm trying to remember
because I all I can remember is being
bored but then I think about it and I
look at Kids now and I'm just like man I
[ __ ] I [ __ ] miss being a kid where
it was like just so easy to like
entertain yourself and I tried to think
back I think I'm not entertained tonight
kids have it easy now yeah yeah because
that because of all the technology they
have access to right like we had what a
Game Boy Advance maybe if you were lucky
if your parents love you enough so
there'd be some things where my parents
wouldn't let me take the Game Boy and
they wanted me to like kind of interact
oh yeah yeah yeah and I would be like
why okay okay okay okay question
question how do you guys feel about
hawks just like city parks like he
doesn't like Park like in general yeah
just just like as as in as a place to go
to you know waste an afternoon or
something like that well for as an adult
as an adult and a kid well as an adult I
think it's fine every now and then you
know across yeah especially in Tokyo
because you [ __ ] need it yeah because
you don't see grass otherwise
London has so much [ __ ] parks and
like lovely scenery and like Tokyo is
like how about one park but you have to
pay to get in yeah yeah yeah
or your yogi park where everyone on
Earth in Japan goes to and it's like
yeah this is [ __ ] yeah yeah I don't know
like because I've I've been waiting to
have a hot take on Parks I just saw I
like I don't know if it's just parks in
Japan or or anything like that I just
don't like them like
I just like for me like for me wait wait
did you like parks in the UK
not really why not what'd you do in them
let's walk it's not like a cinema it's
not like there's something to just walk
you enjoy it you got to make your own
fun
you're like permanently online
what do you mean what do you do you just
go to the park you chill out you walk
you breathe in do you like walking
walking's fine but I can walk anywhere
can't the type of [ __ ] walk
outside being like what's the quest
for Parks right my favorite parks for
example is if there's like an activity
to do at the park like maybe like a
playground or something oh you know
maybe I would can't like on a playground
no no I don't know because
sometimes
the reason I bring this up and it's this
this is why I'm like married to cities
because we have exactly the same
opinions we we we started like walking
around which we explore like we explore
like part of our neighborhood and
there's a park that we've never been to
yeah and we're like oh maybe we should
explore the park that's what that's what
people do on this case right that's what
humans act like right on on days we uh
it's like humans do this thing called
Walking In the Park yeah yeah yeah so we
try it out so we go in the spark and you
have to pay to get in this park so we're
like okay it must be a pretty big park
right yeah which one uh I don't remember
the park name it's it's near to where I
live so I don't really want to doctor
myself yeah um but clearly he doesn't
care there's not a lot of parks in
trouble you have to pay yeah under the
big ones yeah uh so we pay you to get in
and we've paid to get Parts before
normally what we like to do is we like
to cycle around the park there's
normally a lot it's normally big enough
to have like us like a bike rental and
we just cycle around that to me is like
Japan yeah in Japan is there I don't
know there isn't anywhere near where I
live I remember I remember there was one
pretty famous one that's massive thank
you
I'm not sure if it's in Tokyo or saitama
I'll have to double check it but it's
not it's definitely not in like the
center Center yeah you know that's
that's the kind of Park experience I
liked
um sure maybe I just say walking right
because me and Sydney it sounds like you
hate walking me and me and Sydney are
just walking around and being like
where's the fun when does the fun start
you just take it in you breathe you know
it's like good for you to look at green
but
we had this we at this moment where we
were just like walking around uh we were
just walking around and we were just
like you know she was just like walking
around like asking us like uh why do
people go to pogs just like just like
asking each other why do people enjoy
parks and everything like that and then
and then we walked we walk past and
there was there was this one kid just
having the [ __ ] time of his life just
like
like collecting leaves and [ __ ] just
like jumping in them yeah like
collecting them again oh yeah and we
were just like [ __ ] that kid I wish I
was that kid [ __ ] no because kids below
like eight can entertain themselves with
anything yeah they have fun with their
imagination
this is the bonus yeah I was like good
God damn it I wish I was having that
much fun no dude bro that's so nice just
chilling just walking around a block and
just you know having like that 20
minutes are just just nothing yeah there
was just some days where I'm just like I
don't have it often uh because I'm a lot
like where I'm like the majority of the
time when I go outside I'm I'm there to
fulfill a quest but like sometimes some
days man you just wake up or you're
doing some [ __ ] and you're just like
[ __ ] I just need to get out yeah you you
just grab you grab a coffee yeah you
just go out around the park just walk
out of your house just go in a random
direction for like it doesn't even have
to be long 10 15 minutes and that just
refreshes your mind it's so nice no I I
I get that because like to me so it so
why don't you just do that but do it in
a park like why are you expecting like a
[ __ ] QuickTime event or something
because because like okay okay we're
waiting for that one NPC
what are you hoping what did you expect
the park to be I don't know it just
feels it just it's always felt weird for
me you know having to go to a place to
feel happy okay I I I love I love like
the feeling you guys are talking about
but like yeah so to me like that's
that's
spontaneous you know that's that's
spontaneous I love for example so you're
asking why people go to the park on
routine
yes it's is it for like is it for the
environment there's a lot of studies
been done but like just being around
like nature or seeing a lot of like
green nature yeah uh is just generally
quite healthy and it's a kind of a
there's so many studies on it but and
again I don't know any of the top of my
head but it's very relaxing it's good
for you yeah uh and you should do it
yeah that's why I I used to love in
Australia I used to love going on like
bushwalks yeah like you know just like
through the rainbow it's relaxing I love
that because like it's like it's not
exciting and every direction you look
it's just trees but it's nice I do it
um not semi-regularly like every few
weeks I go to the park just walk yeah
yeah like coffee because for me I think
I think what's always like weird not
weirded me out but one one thing that I
I've never like got Parks like
personally is just because it always
felt like so artificial you know in
terms of like I love the feeling of
waking up and just exploring nature and
anything like that and that's why I
really value it on like trips where we
go to somewhere where it is an actual
like you know beautiful place yes where
you just can wake up go to the
countryside and you just get that kind
of feeling Parkers have always been like
I go there and I never
ever I never ever get that feeling of
the same Tranquility it's just like oh
this is if I walk for like 10 15 minutes
I'm gonna reach the end and go back to
City I mean it's just like obviously in
like parks and mainly for cities right
where it's just so much concrete yeah
drab gray yeah it's to I mean it is you
know it's gonna make you feel more
livable that's why like you know
Japan had figured out they were like oh
wait we should probably should have
built more trees in our cities because
the newer parts of Tokyo all have trees
yes everywhere yeah because you realize
like subconsciously in your brain you're
like oh this is so much nicer because
there's nature with the concrete yeah
you know it does something in your brain
where you just feel like oh this is more
pleasant yeah that's why I in my opinion
some of the best cities I've been to are
the ones that are built around the
nature or it's built within the nature
not so much like Tokyo where it's like
let's just take all the nature away
replace with buildings yes and then
maybe every now and every [ __ ] 10 20
meters we'll plan one skinny ass I think
the most parks to City ratio I think
yeah I could be wrong why don't you
could check that Kai yeah and I think
this comes back to when I was a kid
because I I always it always weirded me
out as a kid where it was just like the
concept of just plopping in Greenery in
like a concrete jungle and I mean I get
it now as an adult to be like you know
you need a change of environment or
something like that yeah but I just like
to me as a kid it was I I never I never
went to a park for that if I was going
to a park I was playing footy or I was
going to the playground activity and as
an adult I still mentally like I link up
I link parks to like the same kind of
mental barrier where it needs to be
going there for a singular activity I
mean there's nothing wrong with this
with in your age to want to go to the
park to play footy with your mates oh no
yeah but also yeah it's important for
cities to have communal spaces yes right
in Tokyo where the [ __ ] can you go yeah
it's like an open space
like nothing nothing you have to go
outside it's like yeah Tokyo is like you
know you can't do anything you have to
go towards like [ __ ] uh mitaka like
yeah you know it's it's good to have
options yeah
yeah you're probably walking on the
touristy spots and the biggest one is
Hyde Park obviously that's very touristy
yeah but you know even where like yeah I
mean I lived in London London parks are
like [ __ ] massive to the point to the
point where you forget that it's a park
right right I think that's also played
into the fact that there are a lot of
like small parks in Tokyo as well yes
but it's just I'm just like this ain't a
park this is a patch of grass because
there's some trees in it you know we'll
have oh this is the park there's two
football pitches a pond and a bunch of
other [ __ ] yeah yeah enough space for
you to do whatever you want like yeah
it's valued a lot more I think in oh
definitely Europe than so well not that
it was valued a lot more I think it just
wasn't in the city planning when Tokyo
was being developed like it was not all
about developing space for commercial
use yeah yeah and they were like oh [ __ ]
just trying to build as much
infrastructure in a small amount of
space as possible right yeah yeah but
then obviously now we figured out out
that hey if you build a city with more
trees and more green that people are
happier yeah like I think it is like
there is a correlation between how happy
oh absolutely and how yeah yeah how much
uh nature there is there or accessible I
guess in Tokyo it's like everyone's like
I don't want to just leave Tokyo well
that's such a [ __ ] that's why like I
could never live in like Central Tokyo
and that's why I don't live in central
Tokyo because it's like every time I go
to Central Tokyo I'm like this is drab
as [ __ ] like there's no Greenery like I
and again as someone who grew up next to
a [ __ ] National Park if I don't see
even a little bit of greenery I just
Panic oh you've seen Wales [ __ ]
nothing yeah exactly Fields I like it
but that's it yeah that's what you want
that's what you want yeah even living in
Brighton I would love to take drives
like down to like the South Downs and
everything like that you know just just
get like I don't know to to me that is
what an escape is you know I it to me
it's like a commitment to get into like
a proper environment to reset myself and
I really really like that so so if you
and Sydney don't like Parks what do you
do sorry so if you you and Sydney don't
like Parks or like don't like walking
through Parks what is like the
equivalent that you guys do I know we
just have light in nature yeah so how do
we see nature yeah how do you experience
it I mean normally we just through my 4K
TV I mean normally we just take like a
weekend trip outside of Tokyo or if we
have a date that we normally have an
activity we're doing on that date the
activity isn't going to a park the
activity if we go to a park the activity
is going to a park to do X or to do y or
to cycle around if that makes sense
right to me like it's it's gonna sound
weird but just walking to me I don't
really count that as an activity it's
just a thing that I do
if I'm walking I need a destination to
walk to I can't get that I can't just be
walking for the sake of walking no I
don't know if that makes any sense I
like walking for the second walking I I
get uh I get gone in that sense like I
also like I'm I'm stuck I'm slowly
starting to get better at it because Aki
is definitely the type of person who
just wants to like walk with no
destination yeah and I'm like yeah
that's fun when I do it with you but not
when I'm by myself
then I'm just like well [ __ ] I'm just
wasting time at this point like I would
be doing something else at this time
even though I know in my head this is
good for me yeah right and it's and it's
a good escape from all the other [ __ ]
I'm doing but I think again I'm just
like perpetually just bound to my work
in that sense where I'm trying to escape
and yet in my head I'm just like
free emails right now yeah I don't know
I know sometimes it's about the journey
not the destination but always about the
journey it is always about the Journey
of the destination but sometimes I need
that destination to make me appreciate
the journey just just to just so I can
have that mental that mental thing of
just okay I know where I'm going and
then I could just you know zone out and
just appreciate the journey I appreciate
that a lot of people are just like I'm
just going to do whatever and uh we'll
find out what the destination is along
the way uh I cannot do that [ __ ] [ __ ]
give me a destination give give me an
end point give me a goal to work towards
even if it's just like the most Bare
Bones like simple goal yeah and that
would just like allow me to like just
just tell me I need to like go to a
[ __ ] Family Market yeah it's better
it's better I know there's one around
the corner but I'm like you know what
I'll skip that one go to the next one
yeah yeah to make the journey worth it
even that is fine look you can you can
put me here and the destination here and
go this [ __ ] route and I'll be like
okay let's go that route but if you just
if you just tell me oh let's just go up
here and just see where we go I'm like
no give me a destiny just tell me where
we go tell me where we're ending up is
it a family more is it are we going for
the are we going for the family chicken
just just let me know I don't know yeah
I mean I guess it's strange I guess I
don't really mind because in my head I'm
like oh I should a form of light
exercise yeah right so I'm like oh
that's fine then um you know I'm just
like if in my head if it's exercise I'm
like oh yeah cool no no and like you
know I see it that way as well but again
it's like I I'm more determined to go
through that exercise if I knew where I
was going yeah and it's like and it
could be like super [ __ ] fast super
short it doesn't matter just the fact
that I have a goal to reach makes me
work for the goal and it makes it worth
working towards the goal yeah I think I
also just I think the reason why I like
IRL streaming as well is that I can kind
of pseudo exercise while doing it just
walking around all the time yeah did you
just content machine you know I want to
make content I want to min max
everything yeah I just like the fact
that I can just do create content and be
some somewhat active at the same time
yeah yeah it's kind of nice for sure
because it's like oh okay I don't feel
like such a slob and I can go home and
relax and I feel like oh that was not
bad I was good yeah but then when you
get home and you're like [ __ ] I have to
make contact although I normally drink
when I do IRL so I cancel any better
yeah because like talking about you know
touching grass and we're going going on
like adventures and everything like that
I think I get Slice of Life anime now
like it's just could you repeat that I
think I think I think I get it now
because every time like welcome to the
club hey hey hey finally a fellow Slice
of Life enjoy right here because like
YouTube tutorial anime like what the
[ __ ] I mean a lot of people do like that
but not even explain why I'll explain
I'll explain because for for the longest
time I didn't really like I didn't
really like understand the appeal of
like watching a lot of Slice of Life
anime like especially like and stuff
like that yeah yeah yeah
um and then me and Sydney like we we
we've I've talked about this before we
have this yearly trip to yamanashi where
we explore it's like it's really really
quiet area we explore the area and
something and most of the most the time
we just just do nothing we just like
kind of just
chill and just take in the atmosphere
there's not much to do in yet yeah
there's nothing to do no there's not
much to do I haven't seen you can drink
wine that's it yeah that's all you drink
wine and watch my mouth Fuji that's
right yeah you you can drink wine and
just take in the atmosphere and I'm just
like that is me that is me I'm not
complaining because that's what I like
yeah yeah I'm a fan of both those yeah
and I'm just like
damn it's fun doing nothing you know it
feels really really good just having
this nice experience of just like just
like yeah kind of just doing nothing and
just taking the chance and the
environment in right let's go to that
and I'm like damn I felt this somewhere
before why ever felt this before Oh this
is the exact same feeling I get when I
watch every [ __ ] Slice of Life anime
like why is it fun to watch people doing
nothing yeah yeah and I'm like holy [ __ ]
I think I get anything I'm watching
people do nothing no no no it's it's
this idea I think the appeal of Slice of
Life comes from there where it's like
you know I think a lot of the reason why
science lab especially in Japan is so
popular is because the main demographic
of people who watch Slice of Life are
people who have nine to fives super busy
schedules yeah always working always
have something on their mind and their
one Escape is to just be have this
Mutual feeling of I'm doing nothing
thing but it's relaxing yeah right and
maybe they themselves don't want to be
in a position where you know maybe they
don't have the money all the time to
actually go out to the inaka and I
wonder because that's enough in my head
when I still watch animates like my
brain is being engaged right yeah
even even watching Slice of Life though
yeah even watching really yeah because
I'm watching it and I'm like this is
still doing more than nothing oh no in
my head when I was Slice of Life I am
like brain turn off mode I'm just like
I'm just like watching moving images
so I don't to me I'm watching it I'm
like this is requiring effort to watch
yeah and I I'm I'm just bored yeah
because it gives me like it just gives
me that like same relaxing freeing
feeling I'm trying to like verbalize
kind of the you know kind of the
experience you get when you go to a
place like this in the middle of nowhere
Japan because I'm sure there are other
place like it's it's it's it's not it's
off of Japan it's like that I believe 40
out of the 47 prefectures I like that
nearly all of the prefixes I'm not like
I'm not trying to say that oh doing
nothing and taking the environment
that's a Japanese thing only Japanese
people have figured out how to do that
you know but they've certainly perfected
it though they have certainly perfected
it it's it's definitely what I'm saying
they're like we have optimized doing
nothing
no I get it it's like I just think like
I think the word you're looking for is
like
what I like about it's again it's like
that feeling of like
um because you know I think in a lot of
ways like for me what I like about Slice
of Life is that a lot of Slice of Life
is you know based around a lot of like
the the inaka and like you know in the
mountains of Japan or like in places
where there's like not a whole lot
happening and so yeah the countryside
yeah like the countryside like and all
these characters have to find a way to
do certain things and for me it's kind
of special because I spent a lot of my
childhood like that in Japan like when
my grandma lived in the middle but [ __ ]
nowhere in Miyagi we had to make our own
fun like we were just surrounded by rice
fields we were like all right the [ __ ]
are we doing today right so I think I
relate heavily to that feeling and it's
like kind of looking at my childhood
through like roast into glasses in a
sense but like even as an adult I
sometimes watch Slice of Life you know
like I recently uh you know caught up on
like Euro Camp right yeah and I'm like
why is this still fun to watch for me
even though technically nothing is
happening it's because again it's it's
like that feeling of like being content
with the fact that nothing's happening
but that's what's so nice about it I I
think because I've realized I I don't
know what it is about Japan right but
Japan has just perfected Vibes unlike it
just no matter where you go whether it's
like the city or the countryside locally
a true Instagram all right it's just
literally that Tick Tock meme in Japan
it's just [ __ ] Vibes right I I don't
know why I don't know why I wonder if
that's because you never had the time or
disposable income in the UK to going on
these trips Maybe
huh because there are some places in
Europe in the UK that are pretty [ __ ]
chilled too oh no yeah I'm not saying
this is a Japan only thing right I'm
just I'm just saying that Japan did it
Japan it's it's so easy it's so easy to
find in Japan yeah get your phone
replaced until you have to get your
photos
you know yeah it's like I had a [ __ ]
time of SoftBank so you know what I'm
gonna do to lie down watch some Slice of
Life I think how you're describing how
you view size of life that's how I watch
documentaries right right it turns my
brain off yeah and I just listen really
I wonder if that's how people watch
Trash toast
we might be a slice of Life show to some
people yeah because I you know I just
watch documentaries I'll leave them on
the background sometimes I don't really
need to focus and it kind of makes me
zone out and kind of chill out yeah in a
weird way don't know why but how you
describe a slice of life that's how it
sounds to me but Slice of Life for me
just stresses me out that nothing's
happened it stresses me out that they're
not doing anything right that it's not
moving yeah I think like for example
like that's why I really enjoyed
non-numbiory because like that is like
what my childhood was like in a lot of
ways right like when I was visiting
Japan that's just what it was it was you
go out with your friends you'd find your
own phone nothing [ __ ] happens at the
end of the day but it was still good it
makes you feel this kind of like
yearning Nostalgia even if you've never
grew up in Japan yeah you know
absolutely and that's kind of that's
kind of like what I feel even though I
have no [ __ ] roots in Japan but
watching these shows and uh especially
going to places like this I'm like why
do I feel nostalgic even though I have
no attachment to this place you know
yeah and it's it's it's super it's it's
weird super weird it's super weird but
like I said like I said like Japan is a
country of Vibes and I think there's a
reason why it's become one of the most
instagramable countries on Earth you
know like I'm not saying like I said I'm
not like trying to like hype Japan up to
be like oh you're like normal things
Japanese thing like you know like but
it's funny because in a lot of ways it's
true for a lot of people in a lot of
ways it is true I don't know why this
country is so [ __ ] aesthetic whether
it be like I remember I remember
randomly I think it was like when we
went to the [ __ ] junkadelic the last
time right with all three of us yeah and
uh it's this you know Mexican placing um
uh in nakamegara that we've talked about
in past trash Fest episode well like
last time we went you know we had this
[ __ ] amazing you know Mexican meal
and then as we were walking back from
John cadelic to nakamego station I
remember God just randomly just stopped
and went
why is Japan so [ __ ] aesthetic it's
just like out loud I'm like you good
yeah it's just like that country where
no matter what angle you take you you
just you just like snap a picture
instantly instagramable you know and it
doesn't matter
yeah you go to like a place like golden
guy and I'm just like [ __ ] this this
looks cool this looks so [ __ ] like a
lot of this stuff does look cool yeah
and I'm like that looks totally
different from like just going out to
the countryside and it's just it's a
different kind of vibe but it's still
Vibes exactly it's still Vibes basically
Japan is like Lo-Fi the country I just I
that's why I Slice of Life
ages ago Silver Spoon oh yeah I hated it
really oh I love I love it I thought
something was gonna happen I love silver
and nothing happened
and I was like what the [ __ ] I love it
because what is the point I love it
because nothing happens
that's just [ __ ] storytelling because
something happens but that's the point
they're not it's it's like how you make
a story with no story yes like what they
perfected and it's like who wanted this
well that's like that's like going on to
a Lo-Fi playlist and being like Oh the
musicianship is [ __ ] no I like that it's
like it's like it's like oh there's
there's no musicianship in this
whatsoever It's like because they're not
trying I I admire people who enjoy Slice
of Life I feel like there's just a
mental barrier that is stopping me from
enjoying this whole genre
um and I don't understand yeah and I
yeah I just I just felt like annoyed
when I I think I watched like four
episodes of Silver Spirit why'd you
waste my time
like I thought I thought something was
gonna happen right so before I knew it
was a genre yes yes so I watched it and
I was like waiting for some plot yeah
how do you say that because I think
Silver Spoon is one of the best Slice of
Life
in terms of the job in terms of what the
genre has to offer yeah well I I think
you have to be in it you definitely have
to be in a certain
mood to watch slices what mood no Story
please I want no Story the mood to just
zone out and just Revel in like just a
nice comfy feeling I mean if you ask me
why I zone out documentaries I'm like I
don't know I don't know see because I'm
the opposite with documentaries I'm
forced to listen and my it's like an
active thing because I want to
understand what's happened I feel like
I've watched so many documentaries now
where just the formulas feel so familiar
that I'm like okay I can kind of figure
out everything that's going on right
very quickly I feel for a lot of
people's Slice of Life I guess is like
the the comfort food of anime right
where it's like it's like I don't want
to think about it I just I know I like
this thing even though it doesn't you
know offer me anything new in terms of
an experience right it's just like it's
just something to have because I like it
and that's fine I think what's really
nice about slice of life is just it's a
nice escape from just the Daily Grind of
life you know it's you you get away from
that daily ground because what you do
normal and I may not do that huh does
normal anime not give you the Escape of
a no because it puts you into I feel a a
world that is not maybe not the same in
terms of like the quality but in terms
of like the the just the amount of [ __ ]
that's going on it's like that's another
thing you have to like follow and
maintain and you know understand right
yeah like you know you'd watch any show
and be like okay there's a world and
there are these characters involved in
this world that have to do certain
things and there's this evil thing and
blah blah blah right there's so many
things that's engaging right and and
it's like I'm not saying that's bad or
anything like but I need to be in a mood
sometimes I'm in a mood where I'm like
yes I want something that has a
convoluted story with a convoluted
characters convoluted relationships but
sometimes I don't want to think about
that [ __ ] sometimes I just want to turn
my brain off and watch cute girls doing
cute things
do you ever go on trips and just do
nothing every ship I do is nothing right
so why do you enjoy that
turn the brain off you know you finally
get to there you go there's the answer
but like I don't get that from watching
some people go on trips some people
watch last night I wish I wish I could
do that from a TV show but I think
that's but I think that's why a lot of
it's a different kind though like just
in my brain of watching your
documentaries not the same as going on a
trip and yeah yeah just relaxing and not
thinking about anything but I guess
that's why you know there might be a
reason why Slice of Life is so popular
in Japan is because some people you know
who work the salary of man life yeah who
work the nine to five six days a week
can't afford to go on these also
sometimes it's just about like it's
about the small things you know it is
about like okay
like the smallest interaction can bring
you likes okay so actually I'm just like
I just remember like something that
happened to me on this trip and it just
like it just it was just such a such a
nice by the way my argument is not don't
watch Slice of Life go outside that's
not my eyes I I no we got that yeah
like that doesn't surprise me
I mean for the longest time I didn't
like slices but for me I don't know
maybe it's the older I'm getting
um and the more I my uh likes and what I
want is revolved more about actually
going outside yeah doing stuff no I
totally get that as well I don't know
why maybe there's some scientific reason
that when I you know because I used to
be like online 24 7. and I'd never want
to do anything else yeah but now I don't
know I don't know if it's about job or
what that we're online all the time
that's a big reason why I don't watch as
much anime as I used to because like for
me now it's like yes there's a part of
it where it's like yeah sometimes I have
enjoyment from watching anime and
there's sometimes where I do want to
watch anime like you know I wanted to
finish Euro camp and I did and it was
great but now I have other interests
where a lot of it involves me going
outside and doing real life stuff yeah
and it's like is that me falling out of
anime or is that just me growing up as a
person and my interests change I don't
yeah I don't know I don't know yeah I
mean going back to slice of life I still
don't like every Slice of Life like oh
yeah yeah I still will never ever ever
be able to get into chaon for example
don't you dare [ __ ] slander
I feel so boring I feel like there's
only a handful of Slice of Life that
that I actually enjoy and I've noticed a
pattern that all every Slice of Life I
enjoy are like replications of stuff
that I've experienced before yes like
I've never been a cute anime girl
drinking tea and you know like trying to
form I mean I've had apart from the
forming a band bit that's the uh that's
the only thing I can relate to so
whenever it's anything but that I'm like
because I have those memories of forming
a band and hanging out with Batman's
granted none of us were cute anime girls
and none of us drank tea you know we did
other things instead of that but it that
that feeling of like you know just doing
cool musical [ __ ] together with a group
of friends and the troubles and you know
small turmoils that at the end of the
day don't really [ __ ] matter because
he's just a bunch of kids all right like
that's the part of K on that I connected
with and that's why I enjoyed it [ __ ] it
I saw chaotic like pissed me off I'm
like you're trying to trying to stop ban
you were eating tea and drinking like
you're you're eating cake drinking tea
every [ __ ] day no wonder your music
career is [ __ ] but I do do some [ __ ]
work just a [ __ ] bad practice man
Jesus Christ come on see I can't get mad
at that because that's exactly how my
high school bands went I think we
practice maybe 15 minutes yeah like most
of the time we're just [ __ ] around my
band practice like when okay in like
fully wire band never popped in my in my
band experience this is my [ __ ] bad
experience yeah had nowhere to like
practice our instruments right because
we lived in the city and you can't make
so some you can't make noise so we had
to hire out a studio in order to like in
order to also time mattered yeah so time
[ __ ] mattered yeah we had two hours
to practice we are [ __ ] right in [ __ ]
we were [ __ ] practicing we were like
booking our next get them big and
working towards that so so I was just
like no there is no time to [ __ ] around
no for me it was for me it was oh it's
the weekend let's go to the drummer's
house because the drum set's already
there put up a big [ __ ] mattress on
the doors and the wall so that it's like
sound proof practice for maybe I don't
know an hour and then just my friend
being like you wanna go play the new
Mario Kart yeah let's go do that that
was our band practice so I'm like you
know what you know what you know what a
whole cup of tea time I relate I relate
I'm not drinking tea but I'm playing
some [ __ ] money is probably the most
alien thing to me in existence
it's like I don't get like liking uh you
know giving obsessed with cute anime
girls yeah I already get it I don't like
music and I don't like Slice of Life
yeah it's like the trifecta of all the
things I don't like about anime
and so that's true when people are like
dude you gotta watch Kyle and I'm like
it looks awful for me like this looks
like the worst thing I could watch it
probably is for you yeah like this is
torture yeah yeah I'm not 100 no but
yeah like I was saying before I think
it's all about like
on a trip on a journey like the smallest
interactions the smallest things can
just like be like a happy story so I
remember I remember on this trip uh
we're in like this town in like the butt
[ __ ] in the middle of nowhere we we want
to lunch or whatever so we're like oh
let's let's see what restaurants are
about and uh there was this local sushi
restaurant
and we were like cool I'm I'm feeling
Sushi let's do it and it's kind of like
it's kind of the sushi restaurant that
you there's like a single counter and
the menu them they they ain't no paper
menu it's on the [ __ ] wood blocks
yeah on the wall you know this is like
all school this is like old school hard
level mode you know very there ain't no
tourists that can come here and figure
out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm
just like every time I've been to a
sushi restaurant like this I've had
someone Jeff I've had someone Japanese
to like help me get through yeah we me
and Cindy will feel like we were like
feeling adventurous we're like you know
we've been in Japan for three years I
feel like we can do it yeah let's let's
just let's just go and sure and so and
so we go in and we we have that [ __ ]
Salon experience everyone shuts the [ __ ]
up they look at us
[Music]
you can see you can see the bomb and
sweating and I was like two people
please and they were like is the bar
okay and um everyone's silent like
everyone's silent we sit down and
complete silence the customers stop
talking and then and then the sushi chef
asks the magical words
and
we go where the quest begins yeah and we
go die job and everyone's like oh thank
God that's normally how it goes it does
so it's not me how it goes but
it's literally the equivalent of like in
the cowboy time of the bartender going
are you looking for trouble yeah the
cowboy going not too thank God all right
we're good boys yeah and so as soon as
like that barrier was like removed you
know as soon as he knew that one we
could order and two he can have a like a
basic conversation with us like every
kind of like every kind of barrier just
shattered and they became like so
friendly and welcoming and like the
people next to us were also like very
talkative and everything like that as
well so they like asked us so are you
here visiting or you know are you living
here and uh we explained that you know
we're living here we're like YouTubers
working here and stuff like that and
then they went YouTube and then they
went everywhere YouTuber yes every time
every [ __ ] time and then Sydney and
then we get the like the usual questions
are like where we're from so I say I'm
like from England and Sydney's from
America
I don't know why but it was this is like
one of the cutest [ __ ] things I've
seen right so as soon as as soon as
Sydney says she's from America the sushi
chef like lights up and goes oh my God
my I have a grandson and America right
now right and he starts like he starts
going off about his grandson oh and like
we we we eat our meal and he's just like
you know what I'm gonna call my grandson
right now and I don't know if he's I
don't know if he's awake right now but
I'm gonna try calling him so he gets on
this phone he gets out his phone and
this is why we're asking for this is why
we're getting the bid and stuff like
that so he goes on his phone he like
calls his grandson and I think it's like
1am in America when he's calling it
and he's just and he scrams on picks up
he starts he starts speaking to his
grandson and he then he gives the phone
to us
I don't know what to really say to you
guys
in English yeah in English in English
and I was just like yeah I don't really
know to say either you're um you're
we're just having your at your grandpa's
restaurant it's really really nice and
then we just have a random conversation
he's studying civil engineering nice
talking hero good luck
good luck here you know and just we give
the phone back and I was just like I
don't know what the grandpa was
expecting but he was so excited that I
just didn't want to let him down all you
Americans know each other
oh you're American my grandson's in
America you're you're you're you guys
are friends
oh my God and so we were so cute it's
it's so cute and then so we walk out we
walk out and we start exploring the town
a little bit more and there we fight we
go we go we find this festival or
something that's going on and it's one
of the most random things I'm seeing go
into this little town in Japan and then
there's this festival and there's a band
playing some music and uh the bands were
dressed up as Santa Claus Mario and the
exact same clown outfit I had for the
trash taste after dark special like they
had the exact same clown outfit yeah
so me and Cindy just sit down and we're
just like oh let's let's see what see
what let's let's see what this is about
so we sit down out of nowhere we get
[ __ ] recognized by a random person
there all right so I'm like and and I'm
like holy [ __ ] even here like we are
getting recognized I didn't I didn't
think there would be anyone here that
could you know that that would know
trash taste yeah no like us and
everything like right so we're like
we're we're just so after after that
incident we were just like a little on
guard not on guard but just like oh that
oh that is aware that is a possibility
so we're just sitting down and then
suddenly this random Japanese blog just
sits next sits next to us like we're at
a table he just sits down and we're just
like and then the first thing I the
first thing I thought was I must be a
fan and I look at him it's an old
Japanese guy I'm like this doesn't look
like the usual trash taste viewer
this that doesn't look like a thrasher
and I'm like what do you say in uh what
do you say in Japanese to be like
what what's going on yeah and so the
closest thing he goes is like
konnichiwa's
which could be the most like passive
aggressive way of just being like um an
excuse me yeah because like in English
I'd be like hello mate are you okay and
see if you just in like the closest
thing we could think of is
yeah what are you doing there and then
so he takes his hat off it's it's the
sushi chef we didn't recognize it didn't
[ __ ] recognize him he just [ __ ]
sat down oh my gosh it's the [ __ ]
sushi chef holy [ __ ] like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] did he follow you huh no yes
he says some we have uh we have a nice
to talk to my grandson again yeah we
have a nice little chat everyone's been
acting out yeah yeah we have a nice
little chat and everything and then like
he ends the conversation going like he
looks around and he goes see everyone
here
I know everyone here
it's like Anna's like oh okay boss man's
right here okay this is this is the boss
man
yeah yeah and then and then he goes if
you ever come back here please come back
to my sushi place he goes to me goes
hey let's be friends I'm like oh my God
it's so cute oh my God what the [ __ ]
this is this is like this is like we
need a slice of Life anime revolve
around this guy and I'm like I feel like
I that was the exact moment where I'm
just like
I get slices
I was just like I was just like I don't
know that little interaction just
brought me so much joy right now it's
just I agree with this when it's your
life that's a slice of your own life I
don't want to vicariously look through
it I don't want to [ __ ] watch someone
else succeed in life yeah have a good
time I'm praying for a good time I want
to go out and have it
I was just like you know it's it's just
like little moments like that when I'm
just like yeah
his life is full I don't know I don't
know no that's awesome
I didn't I wasn't expecting that
interaction to be the moment where you
go home and you watch a slice life and
you're like that's like me for real it's
it's
a bit different you know
it never happens it was no it wasn't it
wasn't that exact moment but that kind
of like cemented it for me where it was
just like right oh I I get it it's the
little moments it's it's like you know
you know when you the little moments you
see in Slice of Life where it's just
people going on adventures what I said I
had like the inverse where that is
sort out some [ __ ] other payment for
my other SIM cards and these foreigners
walked in and started and they were like
80 years old yeah foreigners I'm [ __ ]
foreign these other foreigners walked in
uh they were clearly tourists and like
they're like yeah like 80 70 very very
elderly yeah uh and they started talking
to the people and they cleared in
spaghetti Japanese I just got up to them
like hey what do you want by the way
like what are you what are you what's
wrong yeah uh because the Japanese
people
yeah uh and they were like oh uh our SIM
cards don't work and on the top right
corner it says docomo so I think that
they can help me right and I'm like they
can't help you
like I'm like
I'm like they're not gonna help you I'm
Gonna Save You 30 minutes I'm gonna say
30 minutes just leave yeah
it turned out they bought their SIM
cards online and and they they can call
each other yeah you can't it's the way
that they don't give out phone numbers
that's the point where it's like how
many layers do I need to go down to
explain yeah this [ __ ] ain't worse
hey you because they were they wanted to
call each other and I was like yeah you
can't do that no you can't get a phone
number in Japan unless you live here and
you you get a SIM card so I basically
just feel like yeah I'll be honest you
can have the data that works nice you
won't be able to call each other save
yourself 40 minutes grab a WhatsApp
use that yeah I was like this they're
not gonna be able to help you I'm like
babe they don't do these Sims you they
had data only Sim and they thought they
had calls because the advertising on the
plan they bought said calls but it was
kind of like a Skype thing and I was
just like don't bother literally the
dichotomy of the two different
experiences
you're not welcome here you have a great
Slice of Life experience or you can
we're talking about
them I was like hey I'm a customer I
paid the monthly and I've been here for
an hour waiting for to get something to
happen so I don't know man maybe you
should just enjoy your day maybe you
should just have a good time yeah
they're like maybe you want to call each
I'm like you'll be fine no you'll be
right just just move together as a group
you'll be a player I have noticed that
the more from like Tokyo southwards
people are more fun more North not so
fun I think so people are way more
chilled the more south you go in Japan
yeah I mean yeah much south I mean I
guess West yeah Western South way more
chill Southwest yeah yeah because you
start going to like Tokyo people get
more chill also like are super chill
super outgoing and then people get more
chill and then you shoot people are
really chill yeah well everyone is
really willing to talk really outgoing
more North you go the less willing bro
people in Hokkaido do not want to talk
no no so I feel like it's it's kind of
yeah she's kind of like more West yeah
I've noticed it's like like even
Japanese they don't really want to speak
to other jobs no they really don't want
to talk
it's such a weird cultural difference I
don't know if it's like the cold makes
people not want to talk
I think it is the weather I don't want
to open my mouth
I'm going to speed I'm going to speak
from my experience at least whenever you
go to a country that is more known for
like hotter climate things just move
slower right I think so yeah things move
slower and but like
the the offset of that is that people
will just see more chill you know I'll
never forget what you said about
Australia when you went you were like
it's like the UK but everyone's happy
yeah yeah I mean it's true it's true
there's more children it's it's like
it's interesting yeah it's probably it's
probably the weather to be honest yeah
the weather certainly helps yeah I mean
like maybe but it's like there are some
parts of like like Southwest uh Japan
where it's like the weather is not that
great right so me I'm sure the weather
is a fashion but it might be like some
kind of like actual cultural route of
spanning however many generations that
is just ingrained into the the local
culture there I don't know it's like you
shoes really chill everything everyone
talked to yeah just Vibes yeah a lot
more outgoing than when we were in
al-Qaeda it was like the complete
opposite yeah do not want to talk no no
well I feel like Hokkaido especially
during the winter it's just like you
every man for themselves yeah you have
to make your time is more it felt like
they were more open to it in winter
because it was like more touristy right
when I was there in summer it was like a
completely different vibe really just
like what do you hear get out you know
welcome here get out
I don't know that's not bad but you just
feel like no one wants to talk which is
fine I'm not gonna be like hey let's
talk but it's like even just like little
conversations you know maybe the combini
like you know when I went to Starbucks
in case you requests the people were way
more talkative asking questions oh yeah
yeah what are you up to and it's like oh
this doesn't happen yeah Tokyo bro I
mean there's no time for that [ __ ] in
Tokyo everyone's like get out get your
food Ramen [ __ ] off eat it you know in
Okinawa everyone [ __ ] talks to you oh
yeah like it's like you could be in the
middle of the [ __ ] forest and they'll
just be like so what are you up to today
I was like oh I'm not used to this
yeah it's great Vibes yeah
um yeah especially like tropical
climates you know okinawan's like
tropical climate I can see that but I'm
betting I'm betting it's very hard to
get [ __ ] done there that's yeah it's not
a not a whole lot happens over there but
that's but that's kind of like why I
like
I I know we're making a full circle here
but like I feel the most like Slice of
Life anime experience when I'm in
Okinawa oh dude because nothing happens
there but I like the fact that nothing
happens there it's it's it kind of
military other than that but like it
kind of moves at its own time where it's
like it's like you know you could be
going through the whole day in Okinawa
doing nothing you you walk around even
in the city in like naha and everyone's
just kind of like vibing like no one's
it doesn't seem like anyone's like busy
or like you know on the clock or
anything like that or like stressed out
everyone's just like yeah we're just
here we're just just chilling just
living our life you're doing good bro
all right sick yeah it's like shoot well
you know it's just like that's that's
the vibe I get and it's like because I
remember when we stayed uh when we went
to our friend's place uh who lives in
all you know whose parents live in
Okinawa yeah and it's like the most like
[ __ ] traditional Japanese house ever
right like just like literally the [ __ ]
you see in like non-non Bureau like
Slice of Life [ __ ] it's that kind of
house and I remember just like while I
was in that house everything just moved
really slowly and I didn't care about
what time it was or what we were doing
we were just like chatting and chilling
in the living room and just like you
know my friends like Dad like collects
all this suck and he was just like
showing us all this [ __ ] I'm like I you
know it's not like I was like super
engrossed in what he was talking about
but it was like you know what
[ __ ] with this this is kind of nice and
I don't know why I like that because you
guys have like a sanctuary someplace you
go to that
the toilet
that's surely that's yours you spend
[ __ ] 19 in your life ain't no way
it's the toilet for you you [ __ ]
speed run that [ __ ] with those 10
minutes
this [ __ ] like I'll see you
next year when he's on the toilet yeah
no I'm talking because the toilet's like
the hyperbolic I'll see you in 20 years
I'm talking about like a place that you
can go to and it's always going to be
like the same it's always going to give
you like Comfort whenever you need to
like take a break or something like that
can can be like Parks it can be Parks
I don't know for me it's not necessarily
the place it's more like how I'm what
I'm feeling and what I'm doing and as
opposed to the place I feel like then if
I put too much weight on a place and
then it changes or whatever I'll be like
no that's that's the thing right because
I'll be sad that's the reason I brought
it up because I know a few people have
like their own Sanctuary most of the
time it's their home especially if
you've you know moved out your country
without your house your Sanctuary is
kind of like your home and I'm wondering
if you guys have ever had that moment
where you're just like really looking
forward to coming back home come to a
place you haven't been to for a long
time but you've valued for a long time
but then something small changes and
you're like I hate it I hate it how dare
this small thing change even though
that's the natural course of Life yeah
like how dare my favorite restaurant
near my house like [ __ ] closer like
that yeah and you're like how like it
like nothing hurts more like perfect
like yeah so like my grandma's house for
example in Japan is like a great example
of that I haven't been back since she
moved before the pandemic started yeah
and when I say she moved I literally
mean she moved from an apartment that
was like here to the apartment literally
across the road so in terms of local
area nothing has changed right but I'm
going back like at the end of the month
so you know to celebrate New Years and
I'm just dreading I'm like it's the same
but it's not the same something
something about this is not the same not
the same even though it is the same and
it's just like it's still in this it's
still in the same town it's literally
across the road like if I wanted to go
to the old apartment it's like a 30
second walk it's right there but I'm I'm
just dreading there's a part of me
that's dreading where I'm just like
it's not gonna be like it was before
wasn't it and yeah especially going to
your Grandma's place yeah that's
something that always felt like it never
changed like your grandparents place
that was always that was always the same
[ __ ] when you were a kid growing up
teenager yeah I like my Grandma's place
in Australia That's My Sanctuary because
I'm like that [ __ ] hasn't changed in
like 50 years yeah he's been living
there her whole life I'm like that's
good but my grandma here I'm just like
you've changed
how dare you change maybe I'm weird I
always liked you when it changed I was
like really you're you're upgrading or
you're changing things yeah that's cool
but don't you feel like I don't know
don't you feel like you'd lose like even
a little bit of like that Nostalgia yeah
and I mean yeah sure but like does that
I mean for me it's like I don't really I
don't really mind it's whatever
Nostalgia certain types of people man
Nostalgia is overrated I [ __ ] love
them
yeah yeah yeah that's what I gave game
devs have been milking us dry with
Nostalgia dude with the dog [ __ ] remake
that's why they're powering they're
taking that and shoving it back in
if you never look back you can never
tell how far you've gotten man
nostalgia's [ __ ] in fact man like
this is Nostalgia looking back or is it
is it or is it missing or wanting that
Feeling Again of it it's a bit of both
I'd say yeah
I'm retrospective I don't think I just
don't indulge it's looking but I think
Nostalgia is like a combination of
things it's it's the whole looking back
and being like ah you remember the good
old days but also it's the looking back
and being like I remember my not not
where the world was at that point in
time but where I was in that point yeah
yeah yeah and it's like sometimes you
don't miss that [ __ ] sometimes you're
like I'm glad I'm an adult now with
Expendable income and I can do whatever
the hell I want yeah whatever I want but
there's a part of me that also misses
you know my granddad buying me ice cream
at the local [ __ ] store yeah you know
school and stuff like that like that oh
I I miss the [ __ ] out of that
why my brain don't do that I don't know
I don't know why my brain don't like it
your brain is just constantly upgrading
dude I think so I'm like upgrade upgrade
upgrade the new upgrade comes
replacing memory progress must be made
Sea Dog version
103.51 now installing new drives drivers
hold on patching myself
fixing bugs and delicious
yeah uh hey look at all these patrons
though I do you think they feel
Nostalgia let us know in the comments
are you are you are you the kind of
person who looks back on life fondly or
are you the person like Connor we just
want to constantly upgrade either way
for those of you who aren't following
the patreon you should upgrade to being
a patreon follower by going to
patreon.com trash day support the show
also follow us on Twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on Spotify and uh
Merry Christmas once again if you don't
celebrate it happy holidays whatever you
do and there is a time to you know
welcome your family and feel nostalgic
about all the relations you've had maybe
you're in your Sanctuary right now
because you're in your family home so
hope you are having a wonderful time and
I hope that Racist uncle is not saying
some awful stuff right now happy
holidays everyone bye
foreign
[Music]